all right I'm gonna tell you about some
new work I'm taking the lab with
students to [ __ ] n and Dylan Payton and
this is my first time kind of going to
this work in more like detail revealing
all the nuts and bolts of it so I'm kind
of nervous have you done this before so
hopefully hopefully it comes through and
so first when it just introduced the
people who were help me do the work and
and whose ideas largely speaking about
today and that's namely you by Chen
who's sitting right here and he's going
to be sort of filling in his questions
come up to and and Dylan Peyton who's
also been working on this project and
there's larger group here at the redwood
centre for theoretical neuroscience here
at Berkeley were based in Evans Hall and
started as the Redwood Neuroscience
Institute in Menlo Park with Jeff
Hawkins and moved here in 2005 and were
basically a group of faculty postdocs
and students many with backgrounds in
math and physics and engineering and
neuroscience and vision science and
trying to bring ideas from these
different fields to bear on trying to
understand information processing in the
brain very much like this program here
and so I'd like to start by also like
and just talk including a quote from
Francis Crick but sort of a different
nature and I think this kind of gets at
an important question which is kind of a
thread in this meeting which is you know
are there are there sort of underlying
principles that we can try to get at
here in the system and not everybody
believes this and that's sort of you
know embodied in this quote here and to
counter that this this this quote by
Horace Barlow here I think is very
interesting so here is in 1972 this is a
sparse coding paper he's looking back at
the work of hexler and parain in the
1940s and his own work in the 1950s
trying to characterize the efficiency
phototransduction and detection in the
retina and and this you know what he was
showing here is that you know initially
before people really understood the
mechanisms there they thought that
neurons in the retina were noisy and
erratic and so forth and sloppy and just
sort of biology was kind of
you know hacker I guess and and
naturally they understood the actual
mechanisms they could show that the
variability and individual observer
judgments of in light detection could be
mostly accounted for by just the
variability in the world the quantum
fluctuations of light and also in in
terms of known sources of variability in
the retina in phototransduction the
spontaneous isomerization or the
so-called dark light in the retina and
so when you took all these in the count
it looked like neurons were actually
extremely precise and what they could
wake that they could convey and I think
this is an important lesson because
whenever we sort of come along as easy
to sort of look at these neural
mechanisms or things in biology and say
oh well that's that's a stupid design
that doesn't make any sense but there's
a very high bar to cross because you
actually have to have to claim to know
all the constraints that need to be
satisfied all the all the issues that
are a better play there to be able to
make that determination in many cases I
think we've seen this happen where you
know things that we didn't really
understand turned out to be very elegant
designs and I think when one example we
could point to is just simply the design
of eyes itself the design of the eye
this is something where biology actually
had to work with the principle of optics
and we look at all these different eye
designs across the animal kingdom we can
make sense of them in terms of
principles of optics ok so that's I but
this sort of lens through which i'ma try
to view the system today as they're
similar to very similar to how their
principles of optics that can help us
understand eyes there are there are
similar principles that could help us
understand what this what the circuitry
is doing here
and so the way with the way I'm going to
be trying to push this sort of stuff
I've been doing the lab for a long time
is trying to understand what's going on
here in terms of unsupervised learning
principles and the idea of using
unsupervised learning is not so much as
a principle of neural development but
more as a way of trying to understand
the system what the system is doing in
terms of underlying principles of from
optimal kody optimal coding principles
and the idea is that what neurons are
trying to do in this in the system is
they're trying to make explicit they're
trying to reformat take the data that's
coming in and reformat it so as to
explicitly represent under underlying
causes or the things that are actually
going on in the world
and information about how to do that is
contained in the statistics of the data
coming in so this is sort of a Barlow
had a quote the way what he said that is
that redundancy provides knowledge so in
the redundancy and list in the data in
the statistics here is information about
how to organize it and how to sort of
pull it apart and extract extract these
underlying causes okay so that's so and
this is I think where we very much need
principles because you know a lot of
these a lot of these boxes in this
diagram this is by the way this is a
nice redraw the event element in Venice
and diagram of visual cortex where the
the sizes of these boxes are drawn the
area is drawn so as to reflect the
actual amount of surface area that's
consumed in the cortex by these
different areas and the wires the lines
between the boxes the thickness of those
lines reflects the amount of white
matter the amount of wires connecting
those areas okay so you can see the you
know that boxes here like v2 it's just
simply I would say it's still kind of a
black box in the field and in terms of
what it's doing I would I would also
call v1 mostly about the black box as
well I'm in terms of I'm trying to
understand what's really happening in
this system so this is I think you know
where we really need principles to guide
our thinking about what could what could
be going on so three three principles
I'm going to appeal to today these these
are three principles of tried to appeal
to today for trying to understand the
system this is more or less the outline
of the talk so the first is this is this
idea of sparse coding and and we're just
leading to this idea of feature
selectivity which I think most everybody
is familiar with but the second is this
idea of a manifold flattening or
manifold learning and that's a way of
getting equivariance so most people are
familiar with this idea of invariants
and so I'll use my prop which is a paper
cup instead of an it's from a cuppa tea
yesterday right so the idea of
invariants is simply that as objects
move about in the world that you have a
population of neurons in your brain
who's firing is relatively constant
irrespective of the specific pose or
transformations of the object so quit
variance is really the flip side of that
is that there's a population of neurons
which change proportional to the
transformation applied to the object so
is the object mu
to the world there's a population of
neurons that increase their activity as
it moves one way or as it rotates in
another way there's another population
of activity that changes activity
proportional for that transformation so
they're coding for the transformation
not for the object per se okay so this
like the flip side the flip side of
invariance and so I'm gonna argue that
this idea of manifold flattening this is
related to ideas that Cox and DeCarlo
have talked about something that the
cortex might be doing and then a third a
third idea this is this principle of
persistence or slow feature analysis
like Lauren swisscott has talked about
and leading to leading to invariance and
so what I'm going to show here is that
these two ideas of sparse coding and
manifold learning are intimately
intertwined okay then that basically
basically can be thought of jointly
together and that's something that kind
of a sudden new aspect of our work and
something was a kind of surprise to me
initially that ubay pointed out and and
then finally that this idea of
persistence can be used as a way of
learning learning how to embed let Abed
the dictionary of a sparse code into a
manifold okay and finally I just want to
say that maybe this this idea the the
overriding principle here is that we can
sort of establish short-term objectives
for what might be going on the system
rather than appealing to the end task
sort of doing end to end learning and
trying to judge the overall performance
of the system which is very wieldy in
terms of back propagating derivatives
and so forth that we can write down
something that you know this sort of
something not as sort of sort of lofty
as the entire task but short-term
objectives in the system at early stages
of the system the system can use to
self-organize as representations okay
this is an idea that was proposed by
lots of different people in the field
but a paper that was very influential on
me was this paper by David field
entitled what is the goal of sensory
coding right so the the title is very
provocative and the idea is you know
that you can establish can't work can
you really write down a goal of sensory
coding in the system beyond just saying
well the goal of sensory since we're
coding is to promote the survival of the
animal or something like that right can
we come write down a more specific
objective for that in terms of how it
organizes information okay so that's the
spirit which we're kind of approaching
this
okay so let's go first of all into this
idea of sparse coding and so this really
all started with this guy here in the
lower right hand right hand corner
Horace Barlow and this is a picture from
the ratio Club which was a group that
met in Queens Square London and through
the 1950s and was basically a collection
of like this brain and computation
program a collection of neuroscientists
early computer scientists information
theorists who were trying to bring ideas
from these different fields to bear on
understanding understanding the brain so
the computer scientists in the room will
recognize this character here this is
William Ruston Giles brinly Tommy Gould
Donald Makai David Christ father and and
many others was all the basically all
these different neuroscientists and
computer scientists in the 1950s who are
we're doing then what we're trying to do
today ok so it's it's really very
interesting and so these ideas were very
influential on Horace Barlow at the time
and shot Claude Shannon came to this
group and gave a lecture on information
theory and that was very influential and
ideas that Horace Barlow developed so he
had his paper in the nineteenth early
1960s on redundancy reduction and this
later paper in 1972 is where he sort of
first lays out this idea of sparse
coding ok and it's simply they were
stated here that the idea the sensory
system is organized to achieve a
complete a representation the sensory
stimulus as possible using the minimal
number of active neurons and so he's
basically proposing this as a way of
making information explicit ok so that
the idea is that when you do this when
you take the information and push it
high into a higher dimensional space and
make neurons more selective and so it's
a way of making that information more so
explicit about what features are present
in the stimulus and essentially easier
to read out ok and so and another so
there's a couple things that motivated
this hypothesis to him one was his own
observations that as you sort of probe
deeper into the system that neurons tend
to become progressively more silent and
it's not clear now looking back on that
whether that was simply due to
anesthesia that you know as good as you
go deeper into the system and so Ruston
DeCarlo have looked at this more
systematically and shown that it doesn't
really so much increases you go up the
ventral stream but nevertheless these
these representations are tend to be
highly sparse and and the other is that
that is that you have this very high
degree of a completeness in in the
visual cortex so but this diagram is
simply showing to scale it is the number
of neurons and the input layer so this
is layer 4 see this portion here each of
these circular outlines shows the
outline of a cell and a nissl stain so
the number of neurons in the input layer
of visual cortex as compared to the
number of fibers coming in so each of
these dots here represents a different
fiber coming in from the LGN ok so what
you can see here is the system is
definitely not doing dimensionality
reduction in the traditional sense it's
not an information bottleneck in terms
of having to do compression through a
small number of fibers is doing
dimensionality expansion as taking the
data coming in and it's pushing it into
a higher dimensional space ok so one
idea here is that the same same time
you're doing that you're making it more
sparse ok so you're doing it's a
non-linear transformation that that
takes this relatively dense dense
activity is coming here on the LGN
fibers pushing into higher dimensional
space and making it making it more
sparse
okay yeah good question so so I think
the ideas that know if you it doesn't
occupy the whole volume right so as a
higher dimensional space most of that
volume is empty because it's sparse
meaning that so if you think about the
axes of the space right is spending us
most of the time along the ax axes and
not very much time in the quadrants okay
but nevertheless in the sense of like
you know sort of linear whodunits
production if you did pca of the space
you'd find all the eigen values are
essentially significant right it's sort
of like you have you have sort of equal
amounts of variance in all directions
okay as you look but but there's
definitely not the volume is not filled
okay but it's not late it's not so just
falling in a linear subspace okay so
it's pushing out along the at different
axes right okay so okay so this is the I
did the idea that Horace Barlow kind of
laid out and and it's sort of a long
time between that and then when people
actually sort of took that idea and try
to test it quantitatively using natural
seen statistics and this is one of the
ideas that David field first started
looking at in the late 1980s and early
1990s and then when I started working
with him we we developed this model to
try to look at what if we what if we
adapt a model of the cortex a just sort
of hypothesized that what the cortex is
doing is is trying to explain the
incoming data and in terms of a set of
sparse underlying causes so this is the
basic idea here the image data is coming
in so this is the intensity as a
function of space and you have a
population of neurons and the cortex
these are individual neurons and their
activities are trying to explain what's
coming in in terms of a small number of
active units okay so that if you look at
this population of neurons at any given
time most of them are going to be silent
and only a small fraction are active and
which neurons are active changes from
one time point to the next
so we can write down that mathematically
here just as a gender to the model they
are trying to explain the image data in
terms of a set of underlying features so
each of these Phi sub I lives in the
same space as the image think about a
little local patch of neurons analyzing
like a local patch of image this will be
like a 16 by 16 pixel image patch okay
and we're going to try to adapt these
features here so that we can represent
this data as sparsely as possible in
terms of these
activities so each of these ASA biases
our coefficient from one of these basis
functions or features and there and we
take those to be the activity activities
of individual neurons okay and okay so
what what makes this non-trivial is that
it's when there's structure on the in
the input if this were just white noise
coming in this would be a completely
uninteresting and not very well posed
problem okay but if they're but if the
data if the data coming in has some
structure to it this is a way of
learning about the structure in the
input okay and okay so so you'll notice
in this equation that the activities of
the neurons on the right side of the
equation and the data coming in is on
the left side right so what we need to
do is get the ace of eyes over the left
and the I the image data on the right
side and the way do we do that is by
writing down an energy function of the
system and this is basically an
objective function both used for
learning but primarily for determining
the activities of the coefficients okay
how do you compute these coefficients in
response to given image and it's
basically composed of two terms one was
just asked that we preserve information
you could sort of come up with a number
of different metrics here but usually we
use the squared error of how well our
model is matching the incoming data
coming in but this is the most important
part is that we impose a penalty on
activities and typically this is
something like an l1 cost function but
there are many others that also work but
just it just cannot be quadratic okay so
so you typically use a just like the
absolute value absolute value of these
coefficients as the penalty okay so then
the the coefficients are computed by
actually minimizing this energy function
so given you have a dictionary that
someone has given you of you already
learned then for the image coming in you
you you compute the coefficients for
that image by finding a minimum of this
energy function because it can't because
when this is l1 or absolute value
there's not an analytical solution to
this it has to be computed numerically
or iteratively in a neural circuit and
so what we showed later is that you can
actually design a neural circuit that
can do this the kid can exactly minimize
this function this energy function and
that's shown here so each of these
neurons in the system is driven by
computing the inner product between each
of those features and the image and that
basically provides the
forward drive to a neuron and then it
receives inhibitory input from other
neurons and the strength of that
inhibitory input is proportional to the
overlap between the basis functions of
the features of those of those different
neurons okay and then each of these
neurons goes through a real uu
non-linearity in this case so in so in
the stuff I'm going to be talking about
from here on out hopefully I'm not
they're all they're not gonna be
consistent but most of the stuff will be
talking about we're gonna be imposing
positivity on the coefficients so we're
gonna assuming all these coefficients to
be strictly positive in the past we let
them be both positive and negative but
here we're going to be moving in the
train were where they're composed to be
strictly positive okay so they're
strictly positive it turns out that
putting those through a real uu
non-linearity exactly minimizes that
energy function when the cost function
on the coefficient activities is just
the absolute value R that just just
proportional to the active activity
value and and then that parameter lambda
that parameter lambda in the cost
function determines the threshold of the
real ooo
and what's kind of remarkable about this
is this this circuit is exactly a
hopfield network okay so these are just
for those of you know the hopfield
network this is exactly the hopfield
dynamics the only difference is that
we're using a real uu here instead of
tension okay so when you when you put
real OU's here at does sparse coding
when when these when this g matrix is
proportional to the is equal to the the
gram matrix of the of your dictionary
and the feed-forward drive to the system
is just equal to the inner products of
your features with the input okay so
that is to say that you can do this in
sort of a realistic way you can you can
basically you can run this system in
real time and need to provide a time
varying input here this system can track
and provide in real time a stable
solution to those two those two solution
to that energy function in real time
okay to compute a representation a
sparse representation with the input as
it comes in all right so so when you so
when you learn the dictionary this is
sort of a well-known result by now that
they have come out to be localized
oriented and and bandpass similar to v1
neurons but they but then most
importantly I mean people always say
this and I say oh wow anything gives you
Gabor first of all that's not true and
the second thing that I said they're
really important is the most important
part of those
is how how the dictionary tiles the
space it's not that you sort of just
look at these and you have like a zoo of
functions these functions tile the space
in a very interesting way they tire look
like a wavelet okay so this is
interesting and makes connections of the
engineering community because people use
wavelets for image compression they're
know to provide sparse representations
of images that they provide up frame a
complete representation of image data
and so the way they tile the space is
really the most important part of what
you get out of this kind of optimization
strategy not just how they look per se
so that's just a few notes about that
all right so it's this you know sort of
this is sort of a toy model of it in the
sense where we're sort of assuming that
this population of neurons is only
looking at stuff in this box and really
what we're going to have as a system of
neurons that are tiling the whole image
and there's no boxes there right so
we don't choose them we learn them okay
so they can they can be anything they
want to be within this box so if all the
data we're falling along the perimeter
of that box and those dictionary
elements would go and code the perimeter
of the box okay but this is learn from
the input datum because the statuses are
stationary kind of homogeneous over that
all right it doesn't matter how big we
could do this on 32 by 32 patches or
whatever you would get more or less the
same solution okay so so now we can sort
of look at how that system codes a time
varying image we're just providing here
an input patch that's you know it's sort
of a snippet from a movie and there's a
larger image here that's changing right
and we're just looking at one local part
of that movie changing over time this is
the sparse encoding of the image and
just as the reconstruction just showing
we can get our information back so here
it is the image image data coming in
we're pushing it into a higher
dimensional space coding it sparsely and
it provides a complete description of
everything that's that's happening here
okay so it's sparse that's good right we
like that idea
but you know when you sort of look at
this is like hmm you know is that
helpful it sort of looks bewildered
wildering and you know it's it's it's
not clear what's going on and that's
because these coefficients are
essentially unordered okay we just have
a list of coefficients here correspond
to that list of dictionary elements
we've learned and so that's why I kind
of looks bewildering and you know
perplexing but if we take those
coefficients and now order them if we
look at specific pairs we see something
quite different so this is a very much
simpler movie this is just an edge
moving back and forth and now what we're
doing this is just showing a bar chart
of all those coffee
I'm sorry here they're going positive
and negative so hopefully hopefully
ain't flipping back and forth but okay
so the this is just a bar chart the
coefficients going up and down like we
were kind of a like lava showing before
so this doesn't make much sense but now
if we take specific pairs of these
dictionary elements so two two units
have that have similar orientations
nearby is what we're showing here but
you could also take two units that have
sort of different orientations as well
then you get these interesting profiles
of activity where the where you see in
the joints in the joint state space
they're moving through smooth
trajectories okay
so there's something interesting going
on here and if you organize it correctly
you can start to make sense of this
activity and what it means that as you
move along this trajectory that's desta
represents the fact that the edges
moving back and forth okay it's good
gives you a more explicit representation
of that yeah I'm sorry well this you're
right I mean there's not people this is
obvious but you know some people look at
this and they say oh gee you know that
doesn't look very smooth okay and I'm
just trying the joint spit in the joint
stay space right that's kind of what I'm
getting at and if you if you just looked
at just connected pair flies just took
two pairs at random this wouldn't look
like a smooth that we just like you'd
see something go up here down here
something go back and forth here okay
fine I see you're saying smooth is not
the right word okay curved trajectories
shape yes yes much matter scientific
term there right cool shapes okay and
here's another cool shape so here's the
sort of conceptualization of what's
going on right isn't in this joint state
space that was really happening is that
there's this low dimensional manifold
that images are moving upon okay so it's
the space is very sparse we know that
natural images occupy a very small
fraction of the state space of all
possible images there's lots of ways to
show this but moreover we know that this
is continuous and connected okay so it
lies along a low dimensional manifold so
this is just a kind of fanciful
depiction of what that looks like okay
so when we do sparse coding what we're
doing is by virtue of imposing sparsity
we're phos we're forcing the basis
vectors of the pay we're forcing the
basis vectors of the transform to point
towards the data right they have to
point towards the manifold okay and then
say they do that in such a way that they
can code points in between by adding
together by forming linear subspaces
okay so this is why the basis functions
that you learn kind of look like divorce
because the bores are modulated sine
waves and sine waves are functions such
that when you add them together they
shift okay so this is one way of
understanding kind of solution that you
get out it's basically learning a good
set of interpolating functions from
moving along this manifold what we want
to do now is make that explicit as you
move along the manifold we don't want to
have just coefficients that are kind of
bumping up and down we want to have
something that tells us we're moving
along the manifold okay so this is what
leads us to the idea of manifold
flattening okay and this is I would
argue a very important concept in the
idea that occurs in sensory coding in
the system and just like some sparse
coding has informed us about these
representations so all these ideas in
manifold flattening okay
so when we talking about manifolds and
one immediately thinks of a Swiss roll
right and so there was this early work
that came not early now I guess in 2000
to me this is still recent but some of
you in the room were probably born when
this paper come out but so so this is
really exciting when this when this
quirk came out showing you how you could
learn manifold models of data and this
is just showing a bunch of data in a
three-dimensional space so these are all
little data points and these data points
happen to lie along a sort of curved
manifold that folds in out stuff like a
Swiss roll and so obviously if you
applied a PCA to the space to this data
it would basically be useless it
wouldn't tell you anything moreover if
you applied sparse coding to this data
overly or ICA it wouldn't do anything
for you okay so somehow you have to do a
nonlinear transform to get into the
coordinates of this manifold okay so
they develop some algorithms either two
and I'll talk about one in a second for
how to take this kind of a manifold and
flatten it okay so that's cut that in
the goal is to take this data if you
have data coming and it looks like this
the goal the argued goal now is to get
into a space where my neurons are
representing these coordinates here and
and and and the space is now flattened
so this is how lle does it I'm just
going to go through this because it's
very sort of a foundational sort of to
how we're approaching the problem here
so the way lle works is that you have
all these different data points along
your Swiss roll and now you take for
each data point on your manifold you
form a locally you find its nearest
neighbors first of all so that's a data
point in question X is specific data
point and now in the high dimensional
space and you find its nearest neighbors
in the high dimensional space which are
nearby on presumably nearby on the
manifold and now what you do is you form
a linear reconstruction of that data
point from your nearest neighbors okay
and you do that by computing the weights
the interpolation weights these are
forced to sum to one so you compute
these interpolation weights from the
other data point so this is sum of sum
over J not equal to I okay
and this over these other data points so
you basically form a locally linear
approximation of any given data point in
terms of its neighboring day
points okay so that's the first step in
lle it's a locally linear approximation
that should remind you what we just
talked about that's what sparse coding
is kind of doing a locally linear
approximation right and so the SEC next
step is to compute then embedding and
the and the idea in the embedding is now
you want to compute the coordinates of
the corresponding coordinates of these
points X in a lower dimensional space so
here were in a high dimensional space
and now we want to map down to something
like a two dimensional space in the case
of the Swiss roll in a two dimensional
space and for each data point X here we
have a corresponding data point Y here
mapped into the embedded space and the
goal is in in the embedded space and now
we're in the lower dimensional y space
we want the same we want the same
interpolation strategy to to hold okay
so the idea here is that is that we want
any given data point the embedding
coordinate Y point Y to be linearly
approximated by its by its neighbors
okay and we're gonna use the same
weights using the exact same weights
okay so using the same weights we
computed up here then then the ideas now
and this in this system here we were
computing the weights that minimize this
expression and this expression here
given the weights for computing the
coordinates Y okay this is the objective
function for computing the embedding
this is how we compute the coordinates
the corresponding accordance of our data
and points in the manifold is by
minimizing this function with respect to
the Y's and that could be basically
formed as an as a minimum eigen value
problem okay so that's the way that's
the way that works and so now this is
not particularly inefficient because
you're using your entire data set as the
model of the manifold so I give you if I
give you a new data point then basically
your strategy for finding out where it
is on the manifold is to ask well in my
entire data set of like a thousand data
million data points or whatever who had
my nearest neighbors who have I seen
before and interpolate between those so
it's basically you know your manifold
mapping strategy is table lookup right
so you'd like something more efficient
than that and then so that leads us that
this idea of lll locally linear or not
landmarks and so locally leaner
millennion linear landmarks the goal is
the same to flatten a manifold but the
idea is now we're going to tile this
manifold not with the entire data set
as our dictionary but with a specific a
much smaller set of landmarks okay so
this much smaller the set of landmarks
it could just be a subset of our data or
they could be learned okay and now we're
going to approximate each of these data
points in terms of a linear
interpolation between these locally
learning landmarks and these landmarks
are much fewer than the number of data
points or is where me may have a million
data points maybe there's only a
thousand or maybe only 100 of these are
these landmarks X okay so now the idea
is if we can find a mapping between our
dictionary elements Phi so we can think
of these landmarks and our manifolds as
dictionary elements just like in sparse
coding and if we can find an embedding
from our dictionary elements into this
lower dimensional space then our
embedding strategy is extremely simple
and remarkable it basically says for
each data point if I hand you a new data
point along this manifold compute its
sparse code using this dictionary of
landmarks so compute its sparse code
alpha so I'm going to give you some data
point X find its sparse code alpha right
that's basically going to try to grab
the nearest neighbors to it on the
manifold and do a local linear
approximation of it and then it's
quarters from the manifold are given by
remarkably a linear projection of the of
those sparse coefficients the new sparse
coding strata I mean the new manifold
mapping strip algorithm then is compute
a sparse code and linearly project and
linearly collapse into a lower
dimensional space to find its
coordinates I'm sorry I is a dictionary
it's a it's a matrix just like before
it's the columns of Phi are your each
column of Phi is a landmark on the
manifold so the Biss your dictionary
yeah sparsely selecting the neighbors
instead of
far away I'm making a bit of a leap here
okay so it doesn't it doesn't work that
well for the Swiss manifold it turns out
as for the Swiss roll but but in general
it's going to work in higher dimensional
space okay that you can sort of it you
can sort of rely upon the sparsity
principle to kind of weed out and and
pull your nearest neighbors all right so
so so now there's one thing that last
last thing I have to convey which is
that what we've been talking about up to
now in these manifold models is the idea
of a one sparse function of the manifold
okay so it's had the idea of simply
having a simple Delta function and the
idea of them when we have these manifold
is that like the Swiss roll is that I
give you a certain data point where
you're at one point along that manifold
right you're just occupying one point so
we could think of basically the function
on the manifold is like a delta function
we're just sort of sitting at some point
and I'm sort of moving that Delta
function along the manifold so I think
it was a once parse function on the
manifold and we're doing a linear
locally linear interpolation in terms of
its nearest neighbors so now we're going
to generalize to thinking about K sparse
function the manifold okay so instead of
just thinking about being at a single
point I could be at multiple points okay
so I have sort of K K Delta functions
sitting on this manifold and now I want
to do a locally linear approximation of
them so it leads us to this picture down
here so there's two things we're
changing now is one instead of using the
whole data set is our dictionary we're
using a set of pruned out landmarks that
we're going to learn that to capture the
manifold so many fewer landmarks and the
second is that instead of representing a
single point okay a delta function on
the manifold we're gonna have a sparse
function on the manifold okay so in this
case three different Delta functions on
the manifold okay so now we're ready to
look at this picture oh boy okay now
we're ready to end the talk I guess but
now we're ready to look at this picture
and understand what it means and this so
this is basically the topographic ICA
that's when topographic ICA you learn a
dictionary in which the dictionary
elements are ordered okay and so the way
they do it is by imposing and ordering
an advance so for each unit you tell it
that these are going to be your
neighbors you impose a topology and so
in this case a 2d topology and and you
say that you will be most correlated to
your neighbors basically okay and then
the dictionary grows into that solution
so the way we can think about this is
that you know when we get a
representation in this format we're
going to
get a sparse representation using this
dictionary but now that sparse
representation is gonna be spatially
organized into a two-dimensional map
okay and so if I give you an image it's
going to show up as some sparse pattern
here as a collection of sparse bumps
you're gonna see little clusters of
activity and sparse bumps on this
manifold okay and that leads us to this
paper which is in my view one of the
most important papers in natural scene
statistics this paper by Oppo Hoover
inin the curiously entitled bubbles and
the idea of bubbles is just this idea
we're talking about that you have sort
of locally local clumps of activity on
this two dimensional manifold in this
case and this can topographic ICA but
then it really begs the question of a
why two dimensional right well they just
did two dimensional get that's something
you can look at maybe it should be a 3d
manifold maybe it should be a 4d
manifold okay so we really want to learn
that okay and so this brings us to you
[ __ ] ends PhD thesis and this this this
idea of this parse manifold transform
which is as follows that we're gonna
think about sparse coding now the
process of sparse coding normally we
just get a collection of unordered
coefficients representing our signal so
this is some image coming in and we get
some unordered list of coefficient
activities and we're gonna think about
them being now organized on a lower
dimensional manifold and we can compute
an embedding of each of these dictionary
elements to some coordinate so each of
these dictionary elements Phi has some
embedding P these different P's are on
this manifold okay and now when we do
that what we'll see is to these
coefficients which were all activities
which all kind of unordered here we'll
see them showing up as kind of local
clusters on this lower dimensional
manifold and we can think of each these
bumps as having like a center of mass to
it okay and we can code those bumps by
their center of mass which is these red
Delta functions here okay so we can
think of the in this case an underlying
three sparse function coding that coding
the signal and then reconstruct
reconstruct from that okay and the
question is how do we learn this
embedding how do we learn to embed these
these these basis functions here onto
the onto the manifold and that the final
part here is the idea of persistence
then this is where the idea of
persistence comes in to learn this and
so what we want what we desire is that
in the manifold space things are flat
okay so in the data space things are
curved as we
move along the manifold we're moving
along the curve in the space but once
we've mapped successfully matched the
manifold we want things to be straight
what's the mathematical sign that things
are straight well it's just that if I do
linear interpolation of then I should be
able between two points then I should
the point that I land at in between
should be also be on the manifold that's
not going to be true if I try to
linearly interpolate between that point
and that point I'm not going to be on
the manifold okay so I want to stay on
the manifold so this is our objective
function is basically to minimize the
second derivative in the space of these
trajectories okay so having done that
I'm in position then to summarize this
is the sparse manifold transform it
basically completely be a capsule just
follow us we start with data we compute
its sparse code we compute an embedding
of the dictionary P into this lower
dimensional space and then using that
embedding we project these sparse
coefficients into this lower dimensional
space it's invertible so from this lower
dimensional representation up here we
can get back to our higher dimensional
sparse representation and in turn this
is to be a sparse approximation and in
turn back to our image so the red arrows
indicate basically the computation would
be the process of sparse inference and
the green arrows the process of linear
collapse or linear projection a simple
example here of the 2d disk I'm gonna
have to skip that okay so we're just
gonna cut to the chase and show you a
result on video and and this is just
showing results here so so a video
sequence here little image patch moving
along this is as reconstruction over
here on the right so up here is shown
the sparse encoding of that video patch
so just let bunch of twinkling
coefficients unordered as before and
this is the manifold embedding of that
space so this is not ordered because all
we're doing is for computing a
projection into this lower dimensional
space beta so it's not yet ordered but
basically what you can see the thing to
we want to convey here is that we've
taken sort of what sort of very very
fast changing activities here and it's
much represented as if we can sort of
look at in the joint space we wanted we
move on to see more linearized
trajectories basically slower slower
changing activity and lower dimensional
okay that we've sort of been able to
sort of capture
get into the manifold coordinates and
then from this we can what for you can
actually go back we can start the
coefficients
at least partially reconstruct the image
patch this transform is stackable so
that we can actually stack it in a
hierarchy so once you've computed this
embedding beta of the sparse
representation now we can learn
dictionaries again on this embedded
space and rikka laps into a low
dimensional manifold again and and and
so forth okay so I'm not gonna have time
to go into those results maybe we can
talk about them a discussion but the
message I want to leave you with is what
we're sort of thinking about here in
terms of mapping this idea onto the
cortex and this kit sort of ties back to
this diagram but also this IDE these
ideas that Cox and DeCarlo talked about
in terms of thinking about the ventral
stream is doing progressive manifold
flattening so in the image space if you
look at or something like v1 which is
more tied to the image space look at
these representations we'd find these
manifolds entangling and tangled in the
sense that as objects move through the
world they're moving through this space
in very complicated way quite
complicated ways we'd see these
activities changing very quickly over
time and we can sort of think about
these transformations that are occurring
along this stream is trying to
progressively flatten these manifolds
and what we're proposing here is an
algorithm a way a basically a neural
computation for flattening that these
manifolds that's composed of two very
simple strategies one is dimensionality
expansion by sparse coding followed by
linear projection into a lower
dimensional space so the idea is that
each of these stages are not doing a
complete flattening it's kind of you
doing a part you're doing a little bit
of flattening right and then you do it
again and you're better right along the
way okay so so you know I had to go
through that a lot of that facet towards
the end but the basic idea is that we
were trying to convey here is that we've
we found a link between this idea of
sparse coding and manifold learning we
can think of sparse coding as providing
a foundation for doing manifold learning
and and this idea of temporal
persistence and the structure of visual
data can be used can be exploited to
learn these embeddings of the dictionary
into a lower dimensional space to
flatten the manifold and that you know
that this process of flattening manifold
flattening can be accomplished in
successive stages of dimensional
expansion by sparse coding and dimension
they collapse alright so but not very
silent so happy to take questions if
there's time it's not really the point
but so much in terms of I mean of all
that this I mean it's interesting it's
something we definitely want to
investigate more is that thick because
there's obviously a compression
occurring here and we want to sort of
see about that but it but the the way it
would differ from compressed sensing is
that in confront sensing you typically
use like a random projection matrix
right so it's completely unrelated to
the structure of the data and it's not
going to have in general this flattening
property so here we're looking for a
very specific projection so it's related
in the sense that we're not taking
something sparse projecting a lower
dimensional space and we can get back
because of the sparsity but in this
particular case is a special projection
matrix that gives this this this this
flattening this this flattening idea
you know you started out saying that the
point of the visual systems is to
reformat the visual signal progressively
so that it's more useful or that's one
of the things you said and I think
that's one of the things you believe so
this is a stackable system you've made
one stack on top of why don't use you
know what kind of what you started with
can you comment on what how you
reformatted the representation not in
mathematical terms but you I look like
the pictures that you briefly showed
still appeared to be kind of oriented I
don't know if you were trying to
represent receptive field properties to
the extent you can even talk about that
the this here right so these these
appear to be oriented filters gevaarlijk
filters and I'm just wondering have you
reformatted the visual image in a format
that is more useful for behavior
compared to what you started with and
I'm not seeing that they're here still
early days I agree I'm not entirely well
I mean I think I should let you Bay and
pres speak to this as well so we've been
applying this more recently to M NIST
and we sort of do see more sort of
higher degrees of abstraction occurring
here but maybe I'll let you Bay speak to
that to end this for example and you
start with like 32 by 32 are 28 by 28 in
this case the image patch and the first
layer you do smart coating expansion
barrel for complete and you see barest
small strokes like this marker for each
of the numbers and then you go to
Netflix lass and darts Marceline okay
right through this stage and the stage
two basis function will look like much
longer much larger parts like a strokes
longer strokes and along the way you can
actually probe their neighbors in this
amenities in there you met in space at
each of the layers right the first
layers in different small strokes and
they're their neighbors are all small
strokes like the six like a six a small
part and its neighbors in the embedding
space are all like the spa the smaller
strokes and then in this layer to the
lockers neighbors are also longer
strokes in this three layer three and
you see almost a one-member
and a different number like this I want
to emphasize about what you're looking
here is again like when we look at these
things you're you know one shouldn't
just look at the basis functions per se
it's about how they tile the space and
the main point here is just compare this
number of here we only have 200 of these
features up here we have 4,000 of these
down here right so these functions have
two tile
very specifically in each and every
location these are tiling space
extremely coarsely right and so the
beauty of this is that the way these
combined if you want to shift that edge
you just add it together with another
edge and that other edge might be over
here right so you could put this much
smaller dictionary you're getting much
more leverage out of it okay there's a
little bit of sort of more complexity
going on here I grease rather modest
right now and but but I think the main
the main thing I think that that that I
find impressive is that this this
dictionary is much much more compact and
it's more richly structured and and
still a lower dimensionality set and
providing you something close to a
complete description with image data
you don't seem satisfied but okay
clearly this is an unnatural data second
and I'm not so like I would have leaned
towards seeing what the results were on
the natural data side compared to M mist
which is very very you know simplified
and secondly when you don't really want
the necessarily or if you if the result
is that at the top you know after
stacking these we get units that are
more like templates of individual
stimuli that also is not a terribly
satisfying new revelation so I'm trying
to figure out if you are achieving we
represent a ssin if you're not really
training this to do something useful
you're trying to still capture
statistics efficiently trying to do
manifold flattening and the claim is we
have evidence we can show you are
definitely much more flattened up here
than you are down here and so that's you
know number one in terms of these
specific dictionary elements I mean
again I just would put some caution is
still early days ask me next year or
next month hopefully yeah anyways yeah
it's kind of an encoder suck-up kind of
basically you know sparse coding is an
auto encoder but we're basically doing
this with it with this extra constraint
it beyond just sparsity but of
flattening
of course the math is different like the
main eye I guess you know I tried to
give here as a theory behind how you get
there right rather than just sort of
stacking a bunch of real uu units and
crossing your fingers and hoping
something an amazing happens we're
trying to say look here the elements
this is you know based on this based on
the structure of the data and the
mathematics of how you flatten manifold
here is a way to do it right and it has
kind of a similar structure to that in
the end but one of the main differences
this sparse inference doing sparse
inference in between as opposed to just
computing linear projections and Thresh
holding but but those but you know
they're sort of related in that sense
that they're both have those elements
but right so right now it's it's I guess
it's all kind of loosely biologically
possible in some sense this is the LCA
circuit the way to compute the sparse
code is something that you could do in a
local circuit of interconnected neurons
okay so that's so that Maps very well on
to a circuit like you know layer four of
u1 or something like that you could
imagine that happening okay the idea
linear projection I you know what's
that's what could be simpler
so so I don't see anything you know that
I mean if there if anything it's too
simple to map onto the cortex I think so
though you know that would be looking
sort of richer richer things that you
would need here trying to expect from
the consequences for nice use of brain
computation and I would guess for
example that no simply by having now
this manifold representation the many
now predictions or kind of
classifications can be done the similar
simple linear readouts or simple linear
prediction mechanism rights and
something to do representation which
makes no operations computed operations
much simpler that's the whole idea right
I mean you know once you're in this kind
of space then you know classification is
trivial right
but here it's very hard so the question
about how you would evaluate this model
you know once you have a nice snack
version of its and you have the variety
of things would you use some proxy to
like you
would you qualitatively look at the
responses of the filters you know the
various layers so how do you get it
quantitative in some sense measure
quality oh yeah great question I mean
there's lots of measures one could use
right now we're focusing on the idea of
flattening so I would sort of say how
flat is it you know and and still
preserving information so as sparse I
like that part not wanting to get to be
flat so you know hooray but now but now
sort of what degree of abstraction we
have have we achieved and then maybe now
applying this to some task compression
would be something I think could be very
interesting for video to try this for
that so I think there's a number of
different sort of quantitative like
evaluation avenues to take is still
early days you know but for right now
I'm just trying to this is like the
first complete talk I've given on this
work and but that's kind of everything
where things are so yeah I'm sorry next
next year you haven't asked a question
yet yeah the goal is to someone to get
some kind of abstract representation
right and then then that would mean to
me that you want to kind of throw away
information kind of this stuff it's not
interesting right but if you do
reconstruction you always try to
reconstruct you know all the details so
I wonder did you think about that is
there some way to I love reconstructing
details I don't think there's anything
wrong with that I say so this idea that
you have to throw a of information it's
obviously true I mean in some sense but
on the other hand you know the biology
has gone to great effort design
photoreceptors to do single photon
detection right and so there's all this
stuff happening on the retina to take
information and handle it very precisely
that's data about the world and I sort
of take the idea that every photon
counts and you and the detail you're
getting is mainly in the fovea right so
where you're looking is where the detail
is and you're grabbing that detail and
you have short-term awareness once you
move your eyes that detail is gone okay
and you can't use it for something but
in the moment if you're trying to reach
for something and sort of pick up
the carpet with tweezers you need you
need that detail right so so I really I
guess sort of taken I think you want
sort of Ubuntu grease abstraction so you
want maybe information to be sort of
thrown away as you go along and the
complete representation of the stimulus
is gonna be all of these areas together
right this is going to sort of have the
abstract parts and this is going to have
the details or something like that but
the whole system together I think you do
want to model everything
oh yeah yeah yeah please
the key here is the sparsity right for
example if you only have one edge you
can coerce it by the the variational
space transformational space and just
use two numbers but what if you have two
edge you meet then you know just very
close to each other in this case when
you go up to the higher layer okay try
to go back you'll collapse them into one
edge just like we can't show that
hierarchical map or the interpolation
against the innocence in the layer three
my edge is here why edge here and they
have absolutely no overlap and you inter
plate in layer three and go do the
inverse transform what you see is a edge
in between not two areas so that in that
sense that's actually exactly there is a
loss going on here I didn't get into it
but yeah yeah great question I mean I
think ultimately right because you know
the visual and the auditory they
correspond to the same thing in the
world right and there's sort of some
common manifold that encompasses those
is that I could Kevin a Regan question
and I mean ultimately I think that's
where you want to get it's too far from
where I can see with my binoculars right
now but yeah but I think that's yeah but
yeah okay
it still stays there and that's
important that focused a little it's not
moving right but you haven't read the
leaves of the tree in the wind they move
and I really don't care about that much
right so I wonder if it's believe it's
possible to take it sort of serious and
try to reconstruct receptacles for the
next frame right yeah absolutely I think
there's a way to do that because now
that you're in this sort of flattened
representation things are more
predictable I mean it's easier to
particularly this sort of trivial
computation and this is something that
you based on some early experiments with
is using then the second derivative to
regularize the sparse representation
right so given I've seen frame ones and
freight frame one in frame to expect
this on frame three right and so you
need to use that to regularize this
partial representation
[Applause]